ngoại
Hiếu thứ BA đâu
ủa anh trời ơi nó đây nè con
trời ơi đi đâu đây đi đâu đây Hiếu thứ BA
hé lô nặng hơn hông
AI hớt cái đầu dễ thương vậy ngoại ngoại hớt cái đầu hả
hồi Tết quen mua Cho đôi giày đồng hồ với mấy bộ đồ
bây giờ đôi giày là mang hết vừa rồi bự hơn nữa đi
bự hơn nữa đi ha
bữa nay muốn ăn gì
bữa nay con muốn ăn cái gì pizza
pizza hả pizza ở đâu ở bên Kia ở bên Kia mua mấy cái
2 cái đi 2 cái đi he ăn nổi hông
vậy Cho anh a một cái bánh size lớn
cộng một cái pizza phô mai Cao cấp với một cái a
nước ngọt nước ngọt thích hông thích đây
em của thằng Hiếu thứ BA ngủ rồi
có đi rửa Tay đi trời ơi ngủ dễ thương quá chị ơi
bận vừa thích luôn he
trời ơi ủa cái gì vậy
ủa đây để chú Quang lấy ăn cái bự đi nhỏ để đây he
để tối vô nhà ăn đúng rồi hông từ từ
phải chùi Tay sạch sẽ mới cầm được chưa sạch
đây nè chùi Tay vô Cho chú quay
chùi sạch vô rồi bây giờ lau mặt cái đi
cái mặt như là con mèo vậy đó đây nè mọi người
nhìn mặt mày nó sạch sẽ sáng sủa đồ ừ ngon hông
rồi ăn đi SAO lại có bắp cải vậy trai
hổng ăn bắp cải được hả
rồi bây giờ con ăn cái này đi hổng bắp cải
đó rồi rồi coi chừng rớt từ từ nha nấm nha
quá ngon quá ngon hả
có ăn pizza bao giờ chưa chưa hả
tập một là ăn cua nè tập 2 là ăn a cơm tập BA là ăn gà
tập 4 là ăn pizza
tập BA là kiểu thích ăn pizza
mọi người tại vì đối diện có cái quán pizza
vui vẻ người ăn cái cô ăn thử nghe đây cô mời cô
cô ăn cái pizza lấy lộc pizza
dạ đó bây giờ nguyên đại gia đình ăn pizza luôn
pizza ở ngoài
dạ cái tóc này quá dễ thương nè thích cái tóc này hông
cạo lông mặt nữa hả thì ngoại bán này nè rau củ xoài chín nè
cà chua rồi bắp mướp rồi tùm lum tùm la hết
trơn á có gì bán đó nói Chung là trái cây vườn mọi người
nói lại địa chỉ Cho ngoại biết đi số mấy dạ 7 BA 6
thí dụ gặp nữa muốn ăn gì
hết thèm cái gì rồi đúng hông còn còn gì
hả xúc xích phô mai mai mốt mua Cho 100 cây luôn ăn hết hông
nhưng mà bữa giờ có điểm 10 nào chưa
thôi hổng có thì thôi 2 điểm 10 rồi 2 điểm 10 rồi
1+1 bằng mấy 1+1=2
2+2 bằng mấy 2+2 2+2=3
là 2 cái điểm 10 này đâu Ra đây
bây giờ là đang tìm bài toán được điểm 10 nha mọi người
cái này được điểm 10
ô kê nhưng mà cái này là size S
bạn chỉ hông hông chỉ
à cái này được 10 nè mọi người đó được à HOA điểm 10 nha đó
bây giờ 5+5 bằng mấy
5+5=4
mọi người ơi cái điểm 10 Quang cảm thấy là
không phải là của Hiếu thứ BA mà là của anh Hiếu thứ 2
ảnh vô ảnh làm giùm
ăn nữa đúng hông
pizza ở dưới là hải sản hả pizza ở dưới là phô mai
thích liền thích liền con uống hông chú rót miếng
Cho thêm miếng nữa Cho thêm miếng nữa
nhớ chú quan nói con phải ngoan thì chú quan mới thương
con hổng ngoan thì chú quan hổng có thương hổng Cho
dạ con a ngoại nói con phải nghe nó là dạ
giờ nói gì nghe nãy giờ đâu dám vô đây nữa
bây giờ à nó lì ngoại nói con con hổng lại luôn
ờ mai mốt con hổng lại nữa
thí dụ nó nó hổng chịu học toán hông ngoại nói là
nó nhắn tin con nó là thằng này hổng học
toán rồi con hổng lại luôn
khỏi cười đừng cười ở đây này con gửi ngoại
triệu dạ